what about what are your thoughts now
this is really getting into speculation
land there
you've you've mentioned exoplanets were
in the realm
of you know there's this beautiful edge
between
science and science fiction that uh some
of us
a rare few are brave enough to walk i
think in academia you were brave enough
to do that
um i think in some sense artificial
intelligence
sometimes walks that line a little bit
there is so much excitement about extra
terrestrial life
and aliens in this world i mean i don't
know what
how to comprehend that excitement but to
me
it's great to see people curious because
to me extraterrestrial life and aliens
is at the core a scientific question
and it's almost looks like people are
excited about science they're
excited by discovery discovery right
and then the possibility that there's
alien life that visited earth
or is here on earth now is
is uh excitement about discovery
in your lifetime essentially i mean
what do you make what do you make of
that there's recent events where
darpa or dod released
footage of uh these um
unmanned aerial phenomena they're
calling them now uap
they got everybody like super excited
like maybe there is like what
what what's what's here on earth uh do
you follow
the this world of people who are
thinking about
aliens that are already here or have
visited
i don't really follow it they follow me
i'd say because in this field
if you're a scientist of any kind you
get
the people contact us me
there's a lot of them about hey i have
stuff you should see
hey the aliens are already here i need
to tell you about it
and i know there are people out there
who really
there's a believe to it there's a
psychology to it and
it's fascinating but okay so it's
similar to artificial intelligence but i
still but like you i'm still enamored
with the point that it is out there
and that people believe so strongly and
that so many people out there
believe believe and uh
i don't know i i i'm not as allergic to
it as
some scientists are because ultimately
if aliens showed up
or do show up or have showed up uh
you know these are going to be very
difficult to study scientific phenomena
like in fact like going back to cats and
dogs like
i just i think we should be more
open-minded about
developing new tools and looking for
intelligent life on earth that we
haven't yet found
or even understanding the nature of our
own intelligence
because it kind of is an alien life form
the thing that's living
you know in our skull it's so true when
we don't understand consciousness
yeah it's true we don't understand how
biology is hard
you know unpacking it and working it all
out it's a stretch and they say too that
our thinking mind is like the tip of a
pyramid
that everything else is happening under
the hood and but what is happening
but the thing with so the typical
scientists response to you know are
there aliens here
is that we need to see major evidence
not like a sketchy picture of something
we need some cold hard evidence and we
just don't have that
that's exactly right but from my
perspective i
admire people that dream and i think
that's beautiful
the thing i don't like there's two sides
of the of the folks
uh that probably listen to this this
podcast is oh
those that dream i think is beautiful
that uh
that wander what's out there what's here
on earth and then the other ones
who are very conspiratorial and thinking
that stuff is being hidden
right becomes about institutions okay
i have a funny thing to tell you about
that so one of my colleagues had a
really good answer to that
and it's not me saying this so i can say
this but he said look he works with nasa
not at nasa he works with government not
in the government
it's kind of me but he'd say trust me
they couldn't hide it if they tried
do you know what i'm saying like
everybody we're not smart enough we're
good enough
not we or not me or not you but whoever
to cover it up it just
it's sort of a myth yeah
it makes it sad because the people at
nasa the people at mit
the people in academia the people in
these institutions
and yes even in government are often
trying they're like just curious
descendants of apes they're just
they they want to do good they want to
discover stuff they're not trying to
hide stuff
in fact most of them would in terms of
leaks
would uh love to discover this and
release this kind of stuff
and there's a did you ever watch this
show called the x-files
yeah scully and mulder yeah and what i
love actually i used to put it up during
my talks
my public talks there's a picture of a
ufo or what looks like ufo and it says
i want to believe so that's
that's where i think a lot of us are
coming from i want to believe
and it's so great and one time i put
that up
and this very very nice couple
approached me really nervous afterwards
and they said hey can we take you out
for lunch sometime
and i said sure and they were like the
nicest people and just one of many who
has an alien
alien abduction story and the woman
um could never have kids they were older
but they didn't have kids which for them
was a real
source of regret but it was because the
aliens who had abducted her had made it
so that she couldn't have kids
and she had apparently something
implanted behind her ear which was
somehow unimplanted later
and they were just so sincere and
they're such a lovely couple
and they just wanted to share their
story that's that's a real
whatever that is that's the real thing
the mystery of the human mind
right is more powerful than any alien
or i mean it's uh as interesting i think
as the universe and i think they're
somehow intricately
linked
you